when compared to time travel and the
concept of free will the giant humanoid
Rabbit in Donnie Darko is one of the
film's more straightforward plot points
although it has a lot to offer Beyond
just rational explanations it's
impossible to comprehend Donnie Darko
without a basic understanding of its
science fiction elements fortunately
Roberto Grandma death Sparrow wrote her
book the philosophy of time travel on
this very subject at various points
Donnie and his teacher Professor monotov
paraphrase excerpts for us every living
thing Falls along set path
and if you could see your path or
Channel then you could see into the
future right in short the appearance of
the paradoxical jet engine at the
beginning of the movie creates a tangent
universe as the nearest person to the
artifact Donny becomes charged with the
mission to ensure the plane enters the
vortex at the end of the film and
Returns the engine to where it came from
in other words Donnie Darko is set in a
parallel universe where everyone in
Donny's life is unconsciously working to
resolve this jet engine quandary
everything from Donny's Troubled Dreams
to his increased strength that enables
him to put an ax into a statue's head to
his visions of a dead Frank in the
rabbit costume they're all part of the
mythology laid out in the book The
Presence of the engine will eventually
cause a black hole in the primary
Universe which is essentially the
regular timeline for this reason Frank
isn't lying when he gives Donnie the
precise time that the world will end the
Curious can find excerpts online from
the philosophy of time travel and see
how thoroughly it accounts for each
little bit of Donnie Darko as explained
in Sparrow's philosophy Frank is a
member of the manipulated dead because
he dies during the alternate timeline
his role is to be Donny's guide through
his adventure with the jet engine he
wakes him up and serves as the
unsettling Virgil to Donny's teenage
Dante however if you view the movie
through the lens of Donny's potential
paranoid schizophrenia there are a few
clues that the messenger might live
solely in his mind we eventually learned
that Frank is Donny's sister's boyfriend
so it's possible Dani is drawing from
reality Midway through the movie we see
that Donnie has also put a drawing of
Frank in the rabbit costume over his
wall calendar it's not clear if Donnie
Drew this himself and in fact we learn
at the end of the movie that Frank is an
artist when we see his early sketches of
the rabbit mask design did he draw
Donny's picture as well interpretations
range from Frank being a product of
Donny psychosis to the entire story
being something that Frank himself is
remembering as a dream when we see him
touch his eye near the movie's end
Graham Green's story The destructors is
arguably just as important to
understanding Donnie Darko as the time
travel manual as we come to learn Donnie
has lived a life that parallels that of
the boys in the story who destroy an old
man's home Donnie is currently in
therapy and can't drive until he's 21
after accidentally burning down an
abandoned house himself generally morose
and inarticulate about his problems he
immediately understands the motivations
of the kids in the story destruction is
a form of creation so the fact that they
burn the money is ironic
they just want to see what happens when
they tear the world apart this makes
Donnie a perfect vessel for Frank who
directs him to flood the school and burn
down Jim Cunningham's house however all
of his destructive actions in the movie
ultimately served to create the world
Anew and restore order by closing the
loop with the jet engine in a broad and
operatic sense Donnie Darko is an
allegory for what Graham Greene
describes as the pain of puberty when
you become a teenager you enter a phase
of nihilistic destruction whether it's a
goth Punk phase or more aimless
Rebellion against the status quo in
destroying your view of the world you
find an entirely new one which you've
created for yourself in the throes of
early maturation
a big part of growing up is the
acceptance of complexity there's no real
good and evil and the world isn't as
simple as childhood often makes it seem
this is why Donnie sees so thoroughly
and immediately through Jim Cunningham's
self-help stick which involves reducing
every scenario in life to either fear or
love without boiling its message down
Donnie Darko states its purpose with the
story of lingling in the wallet in which
a woman returns a lost wallet but not
the money inside while Donny's teacher
insists that the scenario will be
analyzed on a simple spectrum of fear or
love Donnie insists that not everything
can be categorized or reduced to a
simple explanation our protagonist is
outraged by the fear love Spectrum for
the same reasons he's drawn to
Gretchen's emotional honesty about her
messed up family life he realizes the
full realm of human emotion is available
to him the film makes it clear that if
you spend your life looking for clarity
you'll end up a cardboard cutout of a
person like Cunningham or the Dreadful
Mrs farmer despite having seemingly
unlocked the secrets of the universe
Roberta Sparrow lives up to her grandma
death nickname when she encounters
Donnie and points out that everything
dies alone one could argue that being
one of the manipulated living in the
tangent universe according to her own
Theory Roberta shares this Insight with
Donnie so he comes to accept the
sacrifice he ultimately has to make as
we learn in Donny's therapy sessions the
idea that everyone dies alone is
something he's tired of debating
internally it makes the search for
meaning or a higher power fundamentally
absurd as we age into adults we struggle
to truly reckon with the idea of
mortality Donnie struggles with this
concept especially as he begins to
realize he has to die to stop the world
from ending but unlike his childhood dog
tally he doesn't crawl off to be alone
instead he returns to his family home
dying to save his parents sisters
Gretchen and everyone else he cares
about the most the existential despair
at the idea of dying alone is only
troubling insofar as human connect
action Gives Life Meaning even in her
Madness and Decades of fear driven by
glimpses of the true nature of time and
the universe Roberta Sparrow still
checks her mail every day hoping for
someone to reach out the spears or
vectors emanating from people's chests
that Dani begins to see are a way for
the movie to address an inevitable
Paradox that any time travel flick runs
into free will if you can see your
future it stands to reason that you
would have the option to change it
Donnie follows his own Spirit to the gun
hidden in his parents closet but it's
not until much later that we learn he
chooses to take it with him later
looking at aggression spear he seems to
get a whole dose of her future in a
Flash and so he rushes to Roberta
Sparrow's house Donnie seems content to
operate within God's Channel as he puts
it to Dr monotov and follow his glimpses
of the future wherever they lead he does
seem surprised when the journey to
Roberto Sparrow's Cellar inadvertently
leads to Gretchen's death because he
shoots Frank retaliation with his
parents gun his motivations are as
unclear as the Paradox of Free Will in
the abstract are we the architects of
our own fate or are we just following a
path that we can't see
Donny's English teacher Miss Pomeroy
plays a small but key role in the
climactic events of the movie as the
phrase Cellar Door leads Donnie and
Gretchen to their Fateful Encounter With
the school bullies somewhat randomly
Miss Pomeroy writes the words on her
chalkboard inspired by a quote famous
linguist who claimed it was the most
beautiful phrase in the English language
that famous linguist was in fact the
Lord of the Rings author J.R.R Tolkien
it's a relatively absurd connection and
the artificiality of it is driven home
explicitly when Donnie mumbles a certain
phrase while fighting
deus ex machina refers to a random and
unlikely act occurring in a story
usually to save the protagonist from
certain Peril Donnie seems at least
subconsciously aware that the entire
last month of his life is one endless
deus ex machina all of these unlikely
events are conspiring to achieve a
certain world saving result the reason
Frank has Donnie burned down Jim
Cunningham is one of the more difficult
things to parse in Donnie Darko
according to Roberto Sparrow Frank is
setting an insurance trap to make sure
that Donnie goes through with his
self-sacrifice since Mrs farmer ends up
spearheading Cunningham's defense
efforts she can't accompany the dance
team's Sparkle motion when they get on
Star Search in Los Angeles for this
reason Donny's mother Rose goes instead
as an indirect result of all this
switching the team takes a red-eye
flight back instead of waiting until the
next day so this ensures that Donny's
mother and younger sister will be on the
very plane that loses an engine in
addition to preventing Gretchen's death
Donnie must also reset the timeline to
save his mother and sister this hits a
little harder since he only got to know
Gretchen as a result of Frank's
instruction to flood the school to begin
with
shortly before the dramatic events of
Halloween night Donnie writes Roberto
Sparrow a long awaited letter even
though he marks the envelope extremely
important the letter doesn't really seem
all that time sensitive he says
cryptically that he has lots of
questions for her that he's afraid to
know the answers to the letter ends with
a morbidly optimistic phrase I hope that
when the world comes to an end
I can breathe a sigh of relief
because there will be so much to look
forward to this observation indicates
that he's come to accept his death and
is perhaps aware that it saves the world
in a way but it's also a deep message
about teenage angst and existentialism
in the painful and confusing throws of
late adolescence every problem seems to
have intolerable life and death stinks
once you admit to yourself that the
things you fear won't end the world you
can live freely and be yourself in a
reality that makes no sense in dying to
save the world Dani is facing the
unknown just as every child grows up and
has to define the world for themselves
in its Macabre meditation on fate and
death Donnie Darko arrives at a hopeful
place every day is the first day of the
rest of your life it's not particularly
clear why Donnie drives up to the
mountains with Gretchen's body near the
very end of the movie though it kind of
brings the story full circle it's
possible that what we've seen in Donnie
Darko is just one iteration of a Time
Loop the jet engine creates the unstable
pocket universe and everyone within it
repeats the same span of time until they
successfully transport the engine back
to where it arrived this would explain
why Donnie is already waking up after
sleepwalking at night when we first see
him he's at the beginning of another
attempt when it finally ends he watches
the plane enter the vortex with a
bemused look it's possible he's actually
causing the plane to get caught in the
breach via telekinesis another
explanation would be that he needs to
reach that height to travel back through
the Wormhole himself to return to his
bedroom on October 2nd with the timeline
restored Donnie Darko shows that all of
the major characters Donnie encountered
throughout the story are unable to sleep
on October 2nd clearly haunted by
memories of an alternate timeline that
will now never unfold knowing that our
hero has just died we reflect on how
many people his life actually touched
even though he was generally so
self-possessed with his own issues
haunted by these glimpses Gretchen and
Donny's mother share a strange wave at
the very end of the film a mother whose
world has just been shattered waving to
a young woman from a broken home just
beginning to put her own world back
together as a young adult Donnie Darko
is about the terrifying complex and
hopeful intersection between fear and
love it's hard to decide if it's scarier
to consider the world ending or to think
about it carrying on without us when
we're gone
[Music]